Again, if it's just you and I, it
doesn't really matter. But I'm so frustrated.
Well, hello again.
Alright. We're now live again. My audio is
working. I have no idea what happened.
Hopefully, few of you see this, but we're
gonna continue with the demo because that was
just getting good. And I was actually you
you were doing a Docker Compose demo, and
I was trying to throw questions at you.
And I was like, he's just ignoring me.
That's awfully rude.
That's right. That is the best way to
do a demo. Just, yeah,
just gonna keep going and not stop. Yep.
Alright. So I've I did have a few
questions. I thought I've been able to manage
the builders via Buildx on the CLI and
so the UI is obviously a nice touch.
But it does make me wonder, you know,
how much
you know, there are different types of organizations
out there. For me, I want you to
manage the builder. I don't have to care
about it. I probably wanna pack how much
RAM or CPU. I don't even know if
I get that much control. We didn't get
to go into that much detail. But what
about for larger customers enterprises?
I mean, are they able to provision these
managed things in their own cloud? Like,
how does that work for depending on a
startup and enterprise?
Yeah. Great question. So with this being the
initial release,
what we have today
is a a product that we manage everything
for you.
And so we we manage the builders, and
right as of today,
depending on which tier, there's a
and this is on the the product page
as well too, but there's really only two
different machine configurations,
and it's really based on whether you're personal
or whether you're enterprise customer.
And you can have multiple builders. Of course,
there's gonna be additional cost. So if you're
on a, you know, an enterprise that's got
a hundred developers or a thousand developers, obviously,
you're not gonna wanna share the same machine.
You can you can set up additional builders.
But as of today, yes, we do manage
all the infrastructure.
It is on the road map to provide
the ability to
to provide additional offerings, whether to run those
builders within your own infrastructure
or
even to continue
to use our builders within our our
own infrastructure, but maybe connect to resources that
require VPN access or, you know, inside of
your corporate networks and that kind of stuff.
So there's a lot of different
variants on the road map here. But, yeah,
this is just the initial release that provides
the
fully managed, we run it for you infrastructure.
Okay.
And
when you ran the Docker Compose up,
curious, you know, what's actually happening there? Is
that tearing up my local
directory,
sending it to the builder as doing the
build, and then we're pulling down the image?
Like, is that the kind of workflow that's
happening?
Yeah. So, actually,
how about that? So I'll bring it back
up, and we can
I'm just gonna have to change scene in
case it mutes me again, but let's see
what happens.
Alright. I can still hear you. Yeah. Although,
I've never got random videos showing up by
me.
You wanna share your screen?
Yep. And
there it is. K.
Alright.
Good to go?
Yeah. I mean, I'm sure I'll work out
how to get rid of our big faces
behind us at some point, but right now,
it's not I'm I'm not gonna fix it.
Sounds good. Alright. Then I'll I'll just continue
on. So when I do and and this
is actually the case for any build. So
even if I'm doing a local build,
and I'll I'll just run this and we
can see what's kinda happening here. So what
ends up happening is,
first off, it has to connect to, in
this case, it's connecting to the the Build
Cloud service because that's the builder that I'm
using. It's the driver. But even if I
were using the local driver, it's gonna have
to connect to
the local BuildKit engine that that's running. K?
And then from there, it's basically gonna load
the Dockerfile, and then based on the
Dockerfile,
so and
the Docker ignore file, it's gonna transfer context
for what's what do I actually need to
do this build? So in this particular case,
since I'm just doing a a build and
there's not actually any copies that are occurring
for the the dev stage, I'm just setting
the work directory and and whatnot, that's why
there's only two bytes. And, honestly, I'm not
sure why there's even two bytes there, but
whatever.
While while if I do a a, you
know, the full build,
what we'll see here is that the context
that it's gonna be sending
is a a little bit larger,
but even then, there's not that much because
it's all cached.
So it's computing all the check sums and
everything to to find out, do I have
cache hits or misses
or whatnot before it actually has to transfer
the actual files.
So in this case, if I were to
tweak this, and let's just, I don't know,
turn it to question marks. K?
Now what that's gonna do is invalidate that
layer,
and so what we'll see is that there's
gonna be more cache that more context that's
sent because that particular layer,
let it finish building here. The copy source,
since
that layer needs to be rebuilt, it's only
gonna send basically
this the files for this particular layer. So
it tries to be really smart about what
is actually needed to be transferred, because obviously,
if you end up transferring everything,
then that's gonna slow down things, especially for
larger projects and and whatnot. So it it
does try to be really smart of, hey,
we're not gonna send files for cache hits.
We're only gonna send things for the the
layers that need to be rebuilt, and then
even then, only the source directory
in combination with what's in the Docker ignore
file. So even though, like, I've got the
node modules and everything else here locally on
my machine, well, the node modules aren't in
the source directory, but it's, again, being smart
about what am I actually shipping
to the builder. And it does the same
thing even with the local builder, but you
just don't notice it as much because it's
all just local
file moving at that point.
Then once it's done, it does Did just
send that one file,
or did it send the whole source directory?
Good question. So it does send the whole
source directory in
in this case. Yep. So it's gonna
and that's actually
I wanna say that that our build team
is looking at how it can make that
smarter as well too. But as of today,
yeah, it's sending the
basically, just, yeah, the the contents of the
the source side here, in this case, the
whole source directory. Yep.
Okay.
And then from there, yeah, it builds the
images remotely,
and then it basically downloads it just as
as if it were a registry. So you
will see that all these layers were already
on my local machine. It's only the the
last layer that changed,
and so I'm only pulling down this, you
know, almost
81 and a half kilobytes worth of
content here. Yep.
Nice. Yeah. There's already improvements
performance improvements from that workflow.
Yeah. Just put the way that that works
and speeding things up, especially when a lot
of the network intensive stuff and even the
compilation stuff for different types of languages. You
know, that all happens in the cloud, which
is really what we wanna be seeing here.
So I like that.
Yeah. And I and I've seen with, you
know, projects that have lots of dependencies or
having to download lots of files. I mean,
the the advantage, again, with the Build Cloud
environment is that it's using the the network
pipeline the network pipes that exist on the
remote build service rather than what I have
at home.
And
I know we've all seen, you know, YARN
dependencies or REST dependencies or really any dependencies
can just take a long time to download
everything.
But having
fat fat network pipes in the cloud make
that go much faster.
Yeah. I mean, like I said earlier, with
the the dance class, you know, Monday nights
are when I'm there, and I had to
work from there this Monday. And it does
an NPM install, and it literally took about
thirty six minutes.
That's kind of what I'm like. These things
I don't need to run over my tethered
connection to my phone and some concrete building
with very poor connection. So Yeah.
Well, and and and a good point there.
I mean, so there's a good chance that
even with the the Dockerfile,
again, just depending on what you're building,
you may still be downloading all the the
the contents there, but with, you know, you're
doing an NPM install and it's having to
download every package, like, every single one of
those libraries is yet another network connection and
TLS negotiation and everything that has to occur
there. Well, if this happens in your build,
then your final image has
all that kind of packaged together, and so
you're just downloading, at the end the day,
a single tarball that has all that rather
than having to make those thousands of network
connections and everything else. So even if you
were downloading the same
net
content,
it's gonna be faster just because you're having
to even just do that many fewer network
connections.
Yeah. Definitely.
So I haven't played with Docker Build Cloud
yet. So if I ask you a question,
it doesn't make any sense. Feel free to
shoot me down. Sure. Go for it. I
do see that we can view the build
details and that's Docker desktop link. I'm assuming,
do we get to understand cache invalidations on
what's happening from Docker desktop and from the
web UI?
Yeah. So actually, if I click on this
here,
which I
seen that okay. Maybe the the Versus Code
integration isn't opening up, but I can just
jump over to it. So if we jump
jump over to Docker Desktop, what that's gonna
do is take me to the builds tab
here and basically just open up the the
build that just ran. K? And this gives
me a a lot of details, and I'll
admit, there's
it almost feels like there's too much details,
and so we're still doing a lot of
massaging of
what's the right way to present some of
this so it's not too overwhelming.
But it does give you a lot of
good insights in, okay, where
even this this build that took six point
four seconds, where was the build?
Where where was the time spent? Was it
spent on the the actual build or pulling
the layers? And, you know, the so there's
the the context transfer we were talking about
earlier
and whatnot. So it gives me a lot
of good details here, cache usage as well
too, how much cache is
being used. So there's there's quite a bit
here on the the initial screen.
It does tell me, hey. There here's the
dependencies. And what what's cool about this
is,
you know, if I jump back to the
the Docker file that we actually used here
let me make this a little bit smaller
here. I'm doing a multistage build or I'm
doing from node, but my final engine is
NGINX,
yet in my
build output here, it it understands that this
was a multistage
image, and, hey, you actually had multiple images
part of this. So I can kinda see
what were all the different images, the base
images that were used
in order for me to to do my
build here.
And if I had
additional provenance or SBOM attachments, etcetera, I can
see all that down here as well too.
There's even some open telemetry traces as well
too. So there there's a lot that
comes in here.
Any questions on the screen? Otherwise, I'll jump
to some of the other ones.
No. This is great visibility so far. I'm
I'm looking at it. K. And so, yeah,
source basically just here's the Docker file that
was built.
Logs,
you know, I think we've all had builds
in which,
you know, the the build ran and something
failed, and oops, the error message got collapsed
or swallowed up somewhere else or or whatnot,
and going into the the log output here,
we could see the all the output that
occurred as part of the build. It's all
the console output, and and you get it
in its full entirety, and you can also
see again, here are the layers that were
cached.
This particular one took four seconds. Here was
all the the output here. Looks like we
got some anti character stuff showing up here
too, but
but again, I I can see the full
log output.
And then finally,
the the tree.
This gives me a little bit of details
of kind of this
particular project over time. So, you know, this
was build number six, and this was a
build that occurred, you know, ten minutes ago,
and then another build that occurred about fifteen
minutes before that. And so it's kinda just
grouping it based on the the project name
here,
but I can see, you know, how's cache
usage over time. So the first time I
built this, it took forty seconds, but now
all my subsequent builds are, you know, four
to six second range.
And then I can troubleshoot and debug in
into some of those
builds as well.
So pretty cool.
Yeah. This feels like one of those things
that
the more you use these builders, the longer
they live, the more they do the cash
optimizations that these charts are really gonna start
to show you things that,
like,
that performance is gonna be undeniable after Yeah.
Four weeks, five weeks, especially as software's accurate.
Right? It's not like we're doing major rewrites,
I hope,
every We're
we're changing, adding a little bit of debugging,
adding a trace, adding
whatever, a new environment variable and
seeing
that progression of the cache being used over
long periods of time.
Mhmm. Yeah. That's gonna be super useful. Instead
of like what I do right now, I
am a sucker. I don't know if I'm
a sucker, but I
always just delete
every Docker image I've got every week, every
other week or whatever. I I clean things
up, I tidy up, I get rid of
caches and, you know, pushing all that to
the cloud where I don't even need to
worry about it anymore. And I'm still getting
that shared cache over long periods of time.
And again, especially with a team
that are able to reuse these caches. Like,
why should 10 developers all do the same
compute every single morning when it's just not
that necessary? I mean, I'm already sold. I
see the value of this kind of setup,
which is pretty nice. Yeah. And and so
to to even build on since you were
talking about the the team collaboration usage. Alright.
So let's
let's go back to my
my Docker file here, and let's
let's break it here. Okay? Let's say I
spelled public
with two c's accidentally. Okay?
And and now when I build this, okay,
obviously, is gonna break my build. Okay?
And when I when I do this build,
k, I I get my error message here,
and I
what I can do is if we jump
back to Docker Desktop, first off, I'm still
in the the build output from the previous
one, and it's already telling me, hey, there
was a failed build that that occurred
that's now,
I guess, kind of future in the history
of from the build that I was initially
looking at.
But I can see the the failed output
here. And while I know all these were
for myself,
but if what what's cool here is that
the build history is the build history for
that builder,
not just for myself.
And so if any of my colleagues
built this and created it, you know, during
this build, they ran into failure,
they could say, hey. I'm stuck with this.
Hey, Michael. Can you help me out here?
And I can look into the log output
and say, hey.
Here's where you here's where it's messed up,
and I can help walk them through. So
it's a collaborative debugging experience as well in
which, again, any team member, because it's a
shared runner, all these outputs, all this this
log, all all this stuff here is is
tied to the builder, and, again, I can
help troubleshoot and debug, which is really cool.
Actually, I'll I'll show
if I go to active builds, don't have
an active build, I'll just jump back over
to the
I won't switch the screens here, but I'm
gonna add more question marks to our React
component. And now if I kick off a
build,
which I just press enter here, we can
see that it shows me that there's the
the active build running right now. So I
can see kinda live here at all the
build builds that are running on this
in this particular environment, and then I can
see, yep, I I fixed the build,
and
there it is. So, again, it's trying to
help me have visibility across my entire team
with the shared runner, what's working, what's failed,
and and help troubleshoot. Because one of the
things that we see quite often is that
they're on teams, there are the experts,
and then there's
honestly, to to be completely honest, there's those
that don't care a squat for containers. They're
just like, just spin up the containerized environment,
get it out of my way, and let
me just focus on my code. And so
if something doesn't work right, this gives them
the opportunity to say, hey, you know, Docker
expert on my team, can you help me
troubleshoot why my build's not working here? And
now there's a a mechanism for them to
to be able to do that together.
So Nice.
Great. We've got a question in the comments.
The question is, how does this differ from
export Docker host equals and pointing it to
some sort of SSH or remote Docker engine?
Yeah. Good question. So, I mean, in that
case, you you kinda have a shared runner,
okay,
in which you're
assuming you share that SSH
builder with with everybody on the team, you're,
you know, you've got a shared cache. So
you're getting some of that advantage there.
But the disadvantage is, well, now you have
to manage that machine.
You're having to keep track of, okay, what
versions of of the operating system is it
running? Is it using the latest version of
the the Docker Builder? And, you know, just
all the tooling. Like, that's that's infrastructure you
have to control, you have to manage, and
and everything, which, you know, for some teams,
that that's totally fine, and and you can
certainly do that. The other thing is then
to and I know we haven't done any
multi architecture demos yet, but
if I wanted to build natively for AMD
sixty four and ARM sixty four, now
you could technically still do that with SSH
builders, but it's it's a little bit more
complicated,
and you're having to, again,
how do I scale this across my team?
Here's a bunch of configuration that you're gonna
have to set up across all your team
and whatnot. So this just is a little
bit more of a turnkey solution. It's fully
managed,
fully ready to go, and you can just
get up and going, and, again, you you
don't have to worry about the infrastructure.
Can Can we dive into that a little
bit? Because I think that's a really compelling
use case.
You know, so far what we've done is
you set your Docker
default builder to be a remote builder, which
I'm assuming is a single architecture machine. Right?
It's not running two CPUs and two kernels.
So if I want to do a multi
architecture build and I've got my default builder
set to an AMD sixty four somewhere,
what is actually what's happening for the ARM?
How does it delegate that?
Yeah. So let let's actually
let's give it a shot here. So I'll
just jump back to Versus Code. We'll use
the terminal here. Alright. So let's let's go
back to the the default
builder here. K? And if I do a
build x build, and let's specify multiple platforms
here, Linux AMD
sixty four, Linux ARM 64,
I'll just tag this sample React app. K.
Now when I do this right now,
it's actually gonna fail at first. K? And
this is actually something we're we're doing internally
to
without getting too much under the hood, the
image store that Docker Desktop uses
predates containerd,
and predates multi architecture and everything else. And
so it doesn't actually have support to be
able to store multiple architectures of the same
image as of today.
But there's been a lot of work, and
you've probably seen this show up in the
settings to be able to use,
for example, if we jump over there, to
use containerd for pulling and storing of images.
Like, this is work to be able to
do that, but as you can imagine, there's
a lot of plumbing in Docker Desktop that
has to get replaced in order to use
this tooling here.
And so once that's in place, then, yes,
this will work as you expect. K? But
with emulation. Right?
What? I'm sorry. What was that? But it
builds it with emulation when it's using the
container store. So so, yeah, what what I
have to do is, first, I have to
create basically a new builder.
K?
And what this is gonna do is it
basically creates a container engine that that BuildKit's
gonna run-in.
And
let's just say, let's use that, Nostalgic
Einstein,
which is such a fun name, which actually
maybe let's take a quick little tangent, shall
we?
Just a fun trivia fact here.
For folks that that don't know, all those
names
come from
here's the go code, the name generator.
And there's a you know, it takes a
random adjective
from the left
and then a a random scientist
or
notable scientists or hackers. There's a specifically call
a specific call out, please, for any amazing
man you add to the list, consider adding
equally amazing woman to it and vice versa.
And there's lots of information about it. So
if you're kinda like, wait. Who is this
random name that just showed up here?
Here's where you can find out. But the
fun trivia fact, k, if we go down
to the code at the bottom here
where it actually generates the names,
get random name, it gets the random left,
gets the random right, and if the final
name is boring Wozniak,
Steve Wozniak is not boring, go back and
get a new name. So
there's your random trivia fact for the day.
The only valid use of go to I
think I've ever seen. So Yeah. Exactly.
Alright. So I once got an angry, and
I that was the highlight for me.
Because it's totally true. Yeah. Exactly. So
anyways, now you know if if you're ever
in a, you know, Docker trivia, and it's
like, is never allowed to be boring? You
know it's Steve Wozniak. So
alright. So going back here, I so what
I've done is I've basically built a new
Buildx
engine that's gonna use,
basically, a container to do this build now,
and it then it's gonna use
inside of that, it has container d, and
it's gonna be used in the image store.
Now what's happening here is it's basically bootstrapping
this builder,
and then you'll see
all the different steps. I'll try to get
it so it doesn't scroll around too much.
But each of the the steps will have
okay. Is this the ARM sixty four or
AMD sixty four? Now since I'm on an
Apple Silicon machine,
downloading right now, so who knows what my
network connection looks like right now.
Yeah. You just started upload a download everything
here.
Alright.
It'll get there. Yep,
it's getting there.
Okay. So now we just discovered a new
reason for Docker Build Cloud.
Delegate all of your builds to the cloud
so you can do live streams without worrying
about your bandwidth.
It's it's it's an important concern. I'm with
you.
It it is.
Alright.
So
it's almost finishing downloading here. Oh, that sounds
weird. We're doomed now. That's it.
Russ just put in the comments. So it
was a perfect pause because I am on
Apple Silicon machine audio cuts out. Yeah.
Good call. Good call. Alright. So what's happening
here is you see that it's doing this
YARN install,
and it's doing it both for AMD sixty
four and ARM sixty four.
Yep.
And
since I'm on Apple Silicon, the ARM 64
will run natively,
and so you'll see that that step took
about twenty six seconds.
K? And, whoops, looks like I got a
error of some sort.
And but you'll see even just with this,
k,
the ARM 64,
it it finished in twenty six seconds to
download everything,
while the AMD sixty four variant was still
at forty six seconds and and failed. K?
So
and it would have taken I think,
at least in previous testing, it takes about
two to three minutes for it to to
do that yarn install while emulating,
and it it's just because it has to
emulate the AMD sixty four environment. I don't
have a AMD sixty four chip on my
machine here.
And so, yeah, it kinda stinks.
And I would say it's even more so
profound in, like, GitHub actions
where
I'm building my pipeline. In the in those
cases,
I'm most likely on AMD sixty four machine,
and then I'm having to emulate the ARM
side of things.
And
those builds can take a long time as
well.
Yeah. I've got an open source project written
in Rust called Contrail that we build for
a whole bunch of different
architectures.
And because it it can pretty much run
on anything and there's people doing weird para
PC stuff with it. But regardless,
the
just doing cross compilation
is is a very, slow process, particularly in
GitHub actions. So,
you know Yep. It it really is. Need
better tooling in this space.
Yeah. So And so And how how so
how do we do this with with Build
Cloud then?
Great question. So with Build Cloud, what's nice
about this is
here. Let me just do
Buildx LS, and I'll just show here all
the builders that I have on my machine
here. And what we'll see is that I've
got a builder.
K? And this is that that DevRel builder
that we had before, and it has already
configured.
Here's an ARM sixty four and then the
the AMD sixty four.
And so what's what's happening is, basically, there's
kinda two sub endpoints.
And so now if I
let's say alright. Let's use that builder, and
let's do that same build.
Oops.
Let's do push.
Yep. It's because I need to tag that
with my actual username here.
Oh, well, now a lot of it's cache,
But, again, it's it's gonna be using
the native node for AMD sixty four and
a native node for ARM 64, and so
there's no emulation that has to occur. It's
delegating the work to the right machine.
Yeah. I still think I appreciate that when
we created the builder earlier. I don't so
it's actually every time you create a Docker
build cloud builder,
it's creating a two node setup for AMD
sixty four and ARM 64. Is that right?
Correct. Yep. Okay.
Yeah. Okay. So, yeah, we saw that the
ARM 64 was cached, but the AMD sixty
four, since I I haven't done one of
those builds locally, okay, that took,
you know, about twelve seconds to do the
the whole build there.
And for both architectures,
including image pools and everything else, and and
pushing to to Docker Hub in thirty seven
seconds.
So, yeah, not too bad there.
I like it.
Yeah. So you you mentioned also
or we talked about GitHub actions for just
a second, so I can segue to that
for
and show for this particular project. I have
a GitHub action,
and
all I had to do is and and
this looks pretty consistent with what a lot
of folks will have for
a container image build
using the the Docker action. So, you know,
I log in to Docker Hub,
and then a lot of folks will have
this set up Buildx, especially if they're gonna
do multi architecture build. The only thing I
I had to swap out here, and this
was from a previous
demo,
but
I specified,
you know, the driver for Buildx is gonna
be cloud, and then here's the the endpoint.
Now in this particular case, I would have,
you know, Docker slash DevRel if I wanted
to use the same builder.
Thank you, Copilot, for giving me a suggestion.
That is not valid.
And and so now if I were to
build with, you know, commit this and push
it, my GitHub action would use the same
builder that we were just building with here
on on my local machine, which means my
CI pipeline gets all the same caches or
will populate caches, etcetera,
and leverage that same builder.
And then I can do, again, the the
native multi architecture build, and
it's gonna use those native nodes. So now
in my GitHub action, it's no longer going
to be,
you know, emulating those. And, actually, if I
jump over to the
browser here I know this was a little
while ago when I did the builds,
but this first commit was not using Docker
Build Cloud,
and so the build took about three minutes
because, again, it had to emulate everything on
the ARM side of things. While once I
used Build Cloud, it it dropped the build
to about twenty six seconds.
And, again, for just a little sample React
app, that's a pretty significant savings.
Now I know you've been, you know, talking
about Rust projects and whatnot, and so, yeah,
the more complex the project is, the more
you're gonna see the benefits that come out
with it. So
and it doesn't take much config. It's just
two lines of additional config I had to
provide. So
Alright. Well, I mean, I I don't think
there's any doubt in my mind that people
are watching this and going, I don't want
this. Like, I think this makes a lot
of sense to personal developers,
hobbyists,
as well as teams and enterprises. So
why don't you leave the bad news on
us? How much does it cost?
Yeah. There's always that question, So I'll jump
back to the product page, and and so
what we've got is
there's a a couple different tiers here. K?
And
so there's the personal, and then you can
actually see the the different builder sizes. So,
again, these aren't different sizes that you can
choose from. It's basically you're you're gonna get
the size for the the different tier that
that you've got right now.
And and so you'll see, okay, even for
personal, it's
eight core, 16 gig of RAM, and then
it changes once you get up to the
team.
Everybody gets the the native AMD and ARM
builders,
and and the way that billing works is
by minutes of usage.
Now the the the one caveat I'll mention
is when you're doing multi architecture builds, since
you're building on two nodes, even if you're
you're taking one minute, if it's multi architecture,
that's technically two minutes because you're using it
on two machines at at that point in
time, so just be aware of that.
And so you you get a certain number
of minutes. You can buy additional minutes,
and then there are
kind of throttles for the number of parallel
builds based on
the the tier that you have, and then
you can purchase additional
minutes as well too. So
and all of the pricing, everything is is
on the
let's see. Let's actually go up here.
Go to
my personal one here. So, yeah, as of
right now Now you can start turn free.
Yeah. So as of right now, we're we're
trying to encourage people to to try it
out. And so
so, yeah, the starter again, fifty minutes will
go really quickly.
And so, yeah, you can try it out
for free.
And then from there,
the team
the the build team,
Build Cloud team. Gosh. I can get words
right. It starts at $6 per user per
month, and then that gives you additional two
hundred minutes, and then you can buy reserve
minutes that then
let you kinda pull those minutes and whatnot.
So
Okay.
Alright. I'm gonna ask the hard question now.
Go for it.
Well, this pricing is per user per month.
Right? Now assume I'm on a starter plan,
which of course, I think everyone should just
go and try it because it's free. Right?
Yep. Does that just mean I get one
builder, or can I have 10 builders as
long as I don't have over fifty minutes?
I just So, yeah, we we do limit
right now
the the the free starter ones. You you
get one builder. Oh, okay. We we thought
about that loophole ourselves too. Yep. You you
do just get one builder. And, actually, one
of the things I'll mention too is the
$6 per user per month. Okay? So if
I've got five users, yeah, okay, I'm I'm
paying $30 a month, but each user gets
two hundred build minutes. So I'm I'm actually
getting
a thousand minutes at that point. So you're
200 build minutes per user as well,
which I know isn't
quite crystal clear looking at this, but that's
how that's working.
Okay.
Yeah. I think it's one of these things
people can put their toe in the water,
see if they get you a set of
it, and then Yep. You know, $6 per
user.
When you look at those charts over time
and I'm not I'm not in sales, but
I just see the the value here. But
when you look at those charts, that that
seems like a no brainer for me. $66
per user per month for all of those
cool things that you're getting. So, yeah, I
hope people And I had I had to
find it, and so I I've got this
for you just just to to have it
since we talked about it earlier. So yeah.
There's there really is an s k c
d forever, but I I particularly love this
one just because throughout my my entire career,
it's always been applicable to bar wanting to
build and container energies,
doing get ups, compelling.
It's just Yep. Always there back at my
mind. It's so true.
Awesome.
Alright. Well, let's give people in the audience
a few minutes. If you have any questions,
please feel free to drop them into the
chat. I see that we have another one
from Russell, so I'll pull that up in
a second. I'm gonna move us back over
to big facey mode.
And before we get to any questions as
the as the trickle in, as the trickle
in, maybe you can tell us some super
top secret things that's happening in Docker. What
are we gonna see over the next three,
or nine months?
Yeah. Good question. So,
you know, I I think as
we started off this this conversation with, you
know, looking for opportunities to continue and just
invest and make things easier and continue to,
I mean, add new products and and new
capabilities to the the things that we have.
You know, we we've we started off, you
know, talked a little bit about Scout, and
so I expect to see more in that
space and,
you know, secure software supply chain. I know
there's we've thrown out a couple teasers around
container image signing and verification, so, you know,
be on the lookout for for things in
that space.
You know, in the local development, we've we've
talked a little bit about Docker debug
and the ability to kinda attach debuggers and
bring your own tools to images that don't
have tools already installed in. And and I
actually am a really big fan of that
because that means my final production images can
be really small, really lightweight
without having to package
all my debug tooling into it, and I
can bring it in along. So expect more
in that space,
how we can continue to help debug and
troubleshoot.
And then finally, just, again, thinking about this
kind of, as I talked about earlier, RemoCal
experience,
you know, Build Cloud, you know, Build is
just one area that,
you know, we've we've been able to to
make better, but continue to look more in
that space as well too of how we
can continue to to help just the development
experience be
a little bit easier. And and, personally, one
of the things I'm
trying to to look for as well, especially
with developer relations and training, education, like, how
do we just make
this whole space easier to understand and
because there's a lot. It's there's a large
mental model you have to have in your
head even really just to get going. So
how can we continue to make that easier
for people?
Yeah. You're right. It's a very volatile space.
It's constantly evolving,
and, you know, I feel like I have
to really put in a lot of effort
to keep up with all the advancements. And
then, I mean, I think about the people
that are been in this business for less
than three years or students coming out of
university. It's a lot. So It is. And
and, you know, and I didn't even talk
about, okay, you know, the the atomic jar
acquisition test containers, which I'm That was my
next question.
It's like Did you do it? Well, there's
more than one acquisition. Right? I mean, was
it two years ago? There was tell, you've
got the test container stuff now, and I'm
looking at this along with Docker Build Cloud.
And what I see is a really compelling
future for integration tests and CICD
and local developer experience, like merging composed with
tell test containers.
I mean, I would love to have all
those people in one room and just watch
them for a couple of days. I figured
that would be super exciting.
Imagine there's good stuff coming there, definitely. Yeah.
And and I'm excited too. Even just actually
earlier today, seeing some of the demos with
what the test containers team is doing with
some of these integration points and and everything.
They're like, you know, there's things we thought
about before, but now that we're under the
same roof as the rest of the Docker
team, like, there's some pretty cool stuff. And
I wish I could share more, but you'll
just have to stay tuned.
Awesome.
Alright. Let's get to Russell's question. First, he
says Docker Scout is awesome. That's awesome. Sweet.
And then he says,
I wanna I'm gonna put words in his
mouth. He wants to understand how these minutes
are shared at a team dynamic if someone
is off on leave for a month in
this five hundred minutes. Can you just maybe
dive into that a little a little bit
more? So so as of today, each of
those users are are basically contributing minutes to
a shared pool for that builder.
And so, yeah, if you've got three users
and each of them are bringing two hundred
minutes or whatever, that that six hundred minutes
shared for the entire pool of users for
that that builder. So they're not carved out.
Okay. User one has this much. User two
has that much, etcetera. It's it's a it's
a shared pool.
Awesome.
Alright. Well,
thank you so much for taking time out
of your day. Apologies to everyone who had
to change stream that way through. I still
have no idea what's happening there. But what
I'm gonna do is download all the bites
from both videos, join them together, and then
I'll reupload this as a single artifact. So
yeah. Sounds good. Would be confusing for people
later at all, but, you know That's right.
It'll work. Any
last words, anything you wanna share before we
say goodbye?
No. I just wanna say, you know, thanks
for having me, and thanks for the the
conversations and questions. And thanks for those that
are tuning in and asking questions and
kinda keeping us on our toes. We're we're
always excited to
to demo the things that we're talking about
and and and but also probably more important
to hear the feedback of, like, what would
you like to see? What would you
you know, what would actually help solve your
pain points? So keep that coming along as
well too. And I see Russell put in,
thanks for the demo. It was great even
with the light themed IDE.
I get it. I get it.
I I I'm personally a dark themed IDE
person, but I have found that when it
comes to presentations, I think the light screen
the light themes tend to give better contrast
for screen sharing and projection and all that
kind of stuff.
Yeah. I'm starting to yeah. A person follow
my system. So during the day, I typically
have a light themed IDE. And I think
for the first time in years, I streamed
at lunchtime, like, two weeks ago. And the
first comment was, can you use Docker?
I'm like, actually, I'm trying this thing where
I just let the computer decide what's best.
And I I'm enjoying it. I'm liking the
the change. So, anyway Yep. Yep. Absolutely. So
thanks again. It's been a pleasure. Yeah. Thank
you so much. As everyone watching, thank you
for tuning in. Thank you for your questions,
and we'll see you all next time. Have
a great day. Alrighty. Thanks all.